[Music]
we're going to cook something and i want
to make sure that we have time to do
this so we should head over uh can you
tell us what we're going to cook today
yes we are going to cook some chocolate
linguini wait a minute linguine made of
chocolate you got it this is fantastic
let's do it up here come on
please right this way here we go
you don't cook though i don't i don't
cook uh i don't cook anything i don't
i'm a terrible cook but just the sound
of i love pasta and i love chocolate
just combining the two blows my mind so
show me how to do this so unlike what
you think this is actually a savory dish
it's got pancetta which is bacon italian
bacon which you might really like okay
here we call it bacon bacon here you can
have some when we get there you can have
some bacon okay so this is chocolate
pasta this is like an oh okay it looks
it's pasta that looks like a chocolate
cookie which is fantastic yeah what do i
do i turn it into
linguine okay so what do i do i just
this is this is the one i started a hand
crank like your old gran like your
grandma used to have there you go let's
get an electric kit don't put your
fingers in there okay all right no no
electric for you we're hand making this
okay this just came off is that a
problem
you broke it no just kidding oh it's
supposed to move around i have no idea
i've not used one of these a hand prank
so there you go all right so then it
just came out again sorry i'm getting
nervous
do you have some drinks if you want
something to drink here is this a drink
yes it is what is this it's a chocolate
espresso martini so that should really
take you into another land
that's good
okay andy you got to hit this you got to
try this it's fantastic
you might have to come help him period
that is a chocolate bar martini with
espresso so you're going in two
directions at once yeah i like how you
guys just swap your drinks it's awesome
we don't care we've done everything so
now sticker oh god
that is way too much information now
stick it through there pictures too all
right there we go right down here yeah
go go all right
[Applause]
that's sexy it's everything that was my
rabbi
[Laughter]
so this is fantastic then what happens
it dunks okay it's been on my face you
know what that's right it's boiling in
there
okay so you're gonna cook it for a
minute okay that i can do okay so then
you take the picture
what do i do i'm supposed to watch a pot
for a minute taste what is this right
here
is that pancetta
okay brown butter pancetta
what do you say butter in italy
i should just be giving your italian
lessons except that i don't know this
thing is even on i don't think the stove
isn't on
our show is so dumb
we're doing a cooking segment and the
stove isn't on
just pretend what are you doing
i'm attempting to make things work yeah
can you get the pasta out oh sorry i was
supposed to watch that and i didn't yes
all right okay so my rastafarian curls
are done
there we go right there
dump it in here yeah yeah we're gonna
fake cook it like they do on tv
it's cooking up real nice it's all nice
okay ready yeah there you go mix the
mascarpone in the parmigiano and then
you want to add some vanilla extract
your vanilla what to this oh to that
sure okay what do i do i stand
you didn't tell him how much he just
threw a whole bunch in there it'll be
fine it'll be fine
okay this isn't the part we're eating
anyway this is garbage we're making oh
is this that thing where they yeah yeah
yeah okay there we go we do this and
then when we're done they take out the
one that's been made by there we go
there's the one that's moving don't
touch it is this one oh you switched it
you switched it and it looks beautiful
wow look what we did
okay but at the end you must try
so there's also there's also chocolate i
can't yeah
this is how i eat pasta that's the
problem go down it doubt it you eat it
that's amazing that is good
what is this dish called so i can
pronounce it
hold on chocolate pasta you've got
you've got like mascarpone everywhere
look at that yeah
i had one drink i had one sip and i'm
drunk
andy oh look look fancy fancy fancy
pants
[Applause]
all right yes
all right i am truly heroic okay let me
get that drink uh food network star air
sundays at night
uh no these are for me sundays at nine
on food network giada de la rantis
beautiful fun thank you so much